hello everybody and welcome back to
let's play SCP containment breach ok
they updated the game again which should
solve the fall through the four pumps
but I'm not gonna make you guys sit
around waiting for me to get to where I
was I'm gonna do the trick where I can
accelerate time forward until I get to
where I was look at this all thank you
past mark you did such a good job it got
the ultimate or navigator and a level 3
keycard in the gas mass or right back to
where we was so now since they fixed all
this stuff and radical Larry's dimension
hmm I don't recall any of these ways
because past me went you know in another
place of the bathroom
where's the butt ghost
I will eat your butt oh that's so silly
I don't even know what the point is of
the bathrooms but um but um but um but
um but I'm I'm moving forward cuz I got
I got the means to win no it can't be
this easy oh it can't be this is
ridiculous
ah fudge mutters fudge ah I thought it
was gonna be that easy blood apparently
it's not oh crap crap crap crap crap
crap blink blink blink look like okay
I'm good I also got this special gas
masks on my be using that hey hey hey
stay back you dick
oh wait I'm here all right I'm gonna try
if I get caught by radical area I'll
getting this dimension and I'll do his
thing and I'll get out if I don't then
I'm good either way win-win I'm gonna
try to give to the other side of him
actually no you know what no no I
brought you because I still I should
probably all right radical Larry come on
bring it you dick oh I'm too fat for you
what's going on what's going on what the
hell well that's a what don't what is
this whoa whoa what is this well hang on
what what is this place what is this
what is this I've never seen this before
in my life I don't know it doesn't look
like anything so let's go wait let's go
radical area don't give me don't give me
don't get it do give it I'm gonna run ah
ah ah hey our Oh God okay um
alright I'll save here and I give them
hey buddy
hey stood over there oh hello I'll get
you
I'm Okita oh yeah yeah I read you I
believe I know good ha ha got ya Oh
bonus to the extreme oh oh I know I have
to go is it some dimension eventually
but I want to at least play this safe
and kinda just I want to get to scp-079
who is the computer so I can all I can
get to radical Ares dimension at any
time but I need to get to the computer
sound oh yeah this is a 682 containment
cell god I hope I don't run into that
guy oh I really hope I don't wait ok now
I'm just [ __ ] Parkin giving here hmm
oh no there's no key oh absolutely not
god I'm really glad I have this gas it's
like unbelievably huggable what's with
these doors that are already overweight
that's him this is him
Hot Diggity hot damn
alright please tell me I can get in here
please please yes yeah no no no
oh uh friend body do I gotta like sprint
through there ah yeah nailed it okay hey
buddy
well what the hell is going on here was
with the ground it's kind of foggy in
here hello
seriously what's going on I'm uh I'm a
little confused
okay um what's going on this is door
here that I see hang on a second
it's gotta be something in here right
right there's windows up there I'm
assuming well I mean actually I'm not
sure there's this weird fog on the
ground what's what's the deal well
what's the deal
I can't even we're going on
can't even uh I I don't even what I
don't I don't know I don't know let it
know to mask off know what's going on so
weird I don't know whether its graphical
errors about okay did it bug sings bogs
bugs
hey bugs nothin nothin fudge nutters
alright guess there's nothing I can do
alright
moving on that's stupid if I did
something wrong let me know because
otherwise that's just stupid
alright let's carry on look for
something else I don't think there's
anything else I need to look for besides
radical Aries to mention so I might just
end up going
oh yeah the electoral center what maybe
I got it let me go turn it on maybe I
got to do this first is that it maybe I
had to do this mysteriously lady on and
then remor door trim oh oh maybe that
did it oh maybe that opened that door
oh oh oh
markiplier is so smart how do you even
get so smart
Oh which way did I go maybe I'm not that
smart
which way did I go oh here we go ah how
did she get off still not working and
nope ah what got it did work you I
listen carefully a.m. you need my help
and I need your help
you have this eagle very low board and
roses yes this makes it significantly
harder for me to stay in control of this
facility oh okay it also means you leave
out of here is what your only piece in
the way of escaping this route 80 which
is correctly
like however could unlock the door that
gave you enough of the door control
system if you want tails appear go back
to the electricals and put it back on
okay
do I trust them I don't really have any
other choice I don't think so I'll go
turn it back off oh here oh god I don't
remember which directions I went this
way I think I'm gonna boost something no
no no there's a wrong way the wrong way
wrong wrong I went this way
oh it this way and then I went this way
that's right that's it okay so I turned
it back on and what gave me you'll be
unlock now I don't even know where KP is
but whatever okay okay thank you for you
cool I guess that's it then where's gate
B that's the big question you know I've
never really figured out how to use this
thing is this gay P this isn't gay P is
it
is it not okay so I uh I got a fine gate
B now Oh No Oh kind of creeped out
actually that guy was creepy now must
have been some thug was seeing his like
you know his actual computer screen I
don't know but at least it worked you
know that's the important thing
always look on the bright side of life
ah [ __ ] was that guy out that was the
army oh wow
Oh freaky as hell's and someone was
coming towards me
good god maybe I can trap him in this
beat probably what I need to do right ah
ah you shot me you shot I should have
known that was gonna happen
alright uh let's not do that
apparently they can't open doors
oh I'm glad you're with me oh I hope
Gabey isn't that way I don't know how
I'm gonna get away from him and this
loading tree takes forever I know that
much okay so let's not go that way ah
let's not do that did not do that I bet
he was from gay be gay please now open
they're coming in oh [ __ ] I get that
didn't I oh I'm not good oh I can deal
with this [ __ ] hi buddy
I'm going bye thank you yeah yeah go
suck an egg wait ah ah ah I still don't
know how to use this freaking navigator
doesn't seem to ever move oh wait no
each block is a room oh it's much
farther out than I thought it was gonna
be uh I don't know
hey that's still wrong I'm probably
still wrong probably
this place is not fun to be so why is o7
onion control the facility did he do all
this is he the saboteur or maybe he's
trying to contain stuff I don't know he
seemed pretty malevolent what's this
Oh all right let's summon radical Larry
let's get on that
get on that none others let's get on it
let's get it on tonight okay all right
radical Larry take me
my body's ready where is you are you
coming up are you at
ooh we're uh ah right there okay you're
right there oh hi hi oh my god you touch
me my good
and we're it go go where's that Brno
where is it
who's got it who's got it there it is
good old burn no D so save it here cuz
they should have fixed the falling
through the floor bug so it should be